hi I sometimes hear people saying if you
want to create an artificial general
intelligence that's safe and has human
values why not just raise it like a
human child I might do a series of these
why not just videos you know why not
just use the Three Laws uh why not just
turn it off but yeah why not raise an
AGI like a child seems reasonable enough
at first glance right humans are General
intelligences and we seem to know how to
raise them to behave morally a young AGI
would be a lot like a young human
remember a long while back on computer
file I was talking about this thought
experiment of a stamp collecting a I use
that because it's a good way of getting
away from anthropomorphizing the system
you're not just imagining a human mind
the system has these clearly laid out
Rules by which it operates it has an
internet connection and a detailed
internal model it can use to make
predictions about the world it evaluates
every possible sequence of packets it
can send through its internet connection
and it selects the one which it thinks
will result in the most stamps collected
after a year what happens if you try to
raise the stamp collector like a human
child is it going to learn human ethics
from your good example no it's going to
kill everyone values are not learned by
osmosis the stamp collector doesn't have
any part of its code that involves
learning and adopting the values of
humans around it so it doesn't do that
now some of you may be saying how do you
know agis won't be like humans um what
if we make them by copying the human
brain and it's true there is one kind of
AGI like thing that's enough like a
human that raising it like a human might
kind of work a whole brain
emulation but I'd be very surprised if
the first agis are exact replicas of
brains the first planes were not like
birds the first submarines were not like
fish making an exact replica of a bird
or a fish requires way more
understanding than just making a thing
that flies or a thing that swims and I'd
expect making an exact replica a brain
to require a lot more understanding than
just making something that thinks by the
time we understand the operation of the
brain well enough to make working whole
brain emulations I expect we'll already
know enough to make things that are less
human but that function as agis so I
don't know what the first agis will be
like and they'll probably be more
humanlike than the stamp collector but
unless they're close copies of human
brains they won't be similar enough to
humans for raising them like children to
automatically work blindly copying the
brain probably isn't going to help us
we're going to have to really understand
how humans learn their values without a
good system for that you may as well try
raising a crocodile like it's a human
child human value learning is a specific
complex mechanism that evolved in humans
and won't be in agis by default we look
at the way children learn things so
quickly we say they're like information
sponges right they're just empty so they
suck up whatever's around them but they
don't suck up everything they only learn
specific kinds of things raise a child
around people speaking English it will
learn English in another environment it
might learn French but it's not going to
reproduce the sound of the vacuum
cleaner it's not going to learn the
binary language of moisture vaporators
or whatever the brain isn't learning and
copying everything it's specifically
looking for something that looks like a
human natural language because there's
this big complex existing structure put
in place by Evolution and the brain is
just looking for the final pieces I
think values are similar you can think
of the brains of young humans as having
a little slot in them just waiting to
accept a set of human social norms and
rules of ethical Behavior there's this
whole giant complicated machine of
emotions and empathy and theory of other
minds and so on built up over millions
of years of evolution and the young
brain is just waiting to fill in the few
remaining blanks based on what the child
observes when they're growing up when
you raise a child you're not writing the
child's source code at best you're
writing the configuration file a child's
upbringing is like a control panel on a
machine you can press some of the
buttons and turn some of the the dials
but the Machinery has already been built
by Evolution you're just changing some
of the settings so if you try to raise
an unsafe AGI as though it were a human
child you can provide all the right
inputs which in a human would produce a
good moral adult but it won't work
because you're pressing buttons and
turning dials on a control panel that
isn't hooked up to anything unless your
AGI has all of this complicated stuff
that's designed to learn and adopt
values from the humans around it it
isn't going to do that okay but can't we
just program that in yeah hopefully we
can but there's no just about it this is
called value learning and it's an
important part of AI Safety Research it
may be that an AGI will need to have a
period early on where it's learning
about human values by interacting with
humans and that might look a bit like
raising a child if you squint but making
a system that's able to undergo that
learning process successfully and safely
is hard it's something we don't know how
to do yet and figuring it out is a big
part of AI Safety Research so just raise
the AGI like a child is not a solution
it's at best a possible rephrasing of
the
[Music]
problem I want to say a quick thank you
to all of my amazing patreon supporters
all of these these
people and in this video I especially
want to thank Sara cheda who also
happens to be one of the people I'm
sending the diagram that I drew in the
previous video I'm going to send that
out today or tomorrow I think that's
kind of a fun thing to do so yeah from
now on any video that has drawn Graphics
in it uh just let me know in the patreon
comments if you want me to send it to
you and I can do that thanks again for
your support and I'll see you next time